[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحوادث الكونيه التي تحدث عندنا كجره
ايان وادي الرمه والنقوش البشريه
والمتحجرات التاريخيه تفرض نفسها على
تاريخ العالم اجمع فارضنا معمل جيولوجي
ومتكشف تاريخي وجغرافي وبشري لتغيرات
المناخيه فقد مر علينا عصر الجليد وعصر
السافانا وعصر الامطار الموسميه وعصر
التصحر اللي احنا عايشين فيه ارضنا اخذت
من كل سحابه بمطره وخيره للقريب والبعيد
كالبحر يقذف للقريب جواهرا جودا ويبعث
للبعيد
سحائلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعلاقتنا بالاوديه علاقه معفيه فهي مصدر
للمياه وتجدد تربه الارض للزراعه وتلطف
الاجواء برطوبتها وعلاقها روحانيه
فالجبريل عليه السلام نزل على النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بوادي العقيق اتاني الليل
اتم ربي فقال صلى بهذا الوادي المبارك
[موسيقى]